i thought that would scare you really
are we recording yes
hey guys welcome to the evan caitlin
podcast where i definitely can't
surprise my wife
[Music]
all right guys so in today's episode we
will be talking about um how we started
making products and then why we stopped
then we're going to play two truths and
a lie
and that's it
yeah it's gonna be good yeah it's gonna
be good if you think that by now i'd be
better at like pitching and selling like
what we're doing in this episode or i
mean we're not very good at like i mean
we could say like we're gonna go into
the hold card cold card the cold hard
truth about why we stop making products
i wanna hear about the cold hard truth
you mean the heart the
whole card the old card truth all right
moving on so
um i think that we've told the story
maybe somewhere i just can't remember
where but
we've done it in bits and pieces in bits
and pieces but like our whole product
making journey hasn't ever been in one
concise place
um and it all started when i quit my job
i it had just gotten too much i knew i
wanted to do something else this was the
first job or not the first job but an
earlier job not the job you most
recently quit to
yeah oh yeah the whole like job back and
forth thing that's a whole that's a
whole nother story it's a whole nother
story i mean like i i quit i went part
time i went full time i went part time
and i quit again yeah basically but the
first time you quit
but the first time i quit it was because
i knew i wanted to do something else
and
i just needed time to figure it out yeah
you have enough time to think there's no
mental capacity to figure it out but
then i think once you did quit i think
your first instinct was like making
something yeah and that's because that's
what i had been doing
for my entire professional career i had
been designing
uh manufacturing you know doing
prototypes and then ramping that up to
full-scale production
at a very rapid pace so i knew i could
design things i had been thinking of
ideas for things in my head for the
longest time and uh
and and i thought that that was the path
i wanted to go in a way
that's what i thought i wanted to do
since i was a young kid invent things
make them all of that stuff but i mean
this is kind of getting into another
thing but
through what we're doing now i found out
that the main thing i want to do is
just making things the first time but
we'll get into that later
yeah so so some of the first stuff that
you made and this is before i was really
involved in making any types of products
you were you made some like camera
accessories and stuff yeah camera
accessories i was thinking of uh
some household products one i still want
to do
you know i thought of having you so long
ago i know it's still on our list oh
yeah yeah um one you had was like the
self um
balancing
yeah slider
oh yeah the slider too yeah it's like
kind of like a monopod
um why am i blanking on the name yeah it
was like this like this this fancy like
there's like a omnidirectional ball
in it and then weights and then like it
could be like a
like monopod or
a like stabilizer stabilizing and like i
just love multi-function things i like
things that are small that can do a
whole bunch of things yeah i just like
that's if i were to have an obsession
for like a type of product
that's what it would be
if somebody came to you and was like
what's your favorite type of product
multifunctional small things that do a
lot of things
but uh that's the direction i was going
in and
uh
that's when we got the 3d printer so you
could start like prototyping
and then i also opened that printer up
for like helping manufacture things for
other people and i was doing that and i
was doing it yeah um 3d hubs right is
that what it's called where people can
submit designs although that's uh no
longer what they do they always see
outside they don't do it for like
hobbyists anymore it's only professional
people oh i didn't know that yeah the
whole the whole 3d printing industry is
still so much in flux it's crazy well
that was hard to make any like
reasonable money on because it was so it
wasn't time efficient and also like the
most people aren't aware of the
limitations of 3d printing and their
expectations are
that it's just like magic and it comes
out perfect yeah it's it's there's a
mismatch between reality and
expectations but at least at the time
when you were doing it it was still yeah
pretty new and kind of like mysterious
yeah but then for christmas i made the
3d printed deer for you and then
it's just to describe it people haven't
seen it it's like he he made this this
thing for me and i'm not sure what gave
you the idea to make it initially or why
i forget we were into like geometric
deer heads though or like geometry yeah
but also i think i was just messing
around with 3d modeling programs yeah
and one of the programs is a mesh
3d
like program because you can either have
parametric mathematical based modeling
or you can have polygonal modeling with
like meshes and triangles and and stuff
like that and
i wanted to understand both and i had
some experience with the mesh based
thing when i was doing animations for
work
and i just wanted to keep up my skills
so
i got into modeling animals
yeah
okay so i was just really like a
practice run for your uh skills
you were a very important part of my
choices
yeah so just so you can picture it it's
it's
a 3d printed kind of geometric faceted
deer head that he painted gold
yeah the original one like a deer head
bust yeah like a deer like a deer head
yeah not really the bust kind of starts
with a neck yeah yeah yeah with like
cool over exaggerated antlers and stuff
yeah and and i don't know what i think i
was just doing research one day on like
where we could sell
products at a uh
smaller scale yeah locally smaller scale
because another thing that i thought
about selling are the marquee letters
and that's actually what led us down the
path of selling products because we're
like let's let's start selling something
now what's something that we know people
want people want to buy the marquee
letters yeah and we've done a ton of
requests for them exactly like back when
in the blogging days we would get
requests all the time and even still
sometimes from like friends and family
can we like can
we borrow them yeah can we borrow them
or can we pay you to make us some and
yeah um so we're like okay well there's
demand there where can we sell these
things we can't do it online like via
etsy because they're huge and you can't
we just couldn't ship them reasonably
yeah and they're kind of weighty and
this it's just shipping them is big and
awkward yeah shipping would be terrible
so we're like okay it's got to be local
yeah so we uh found local places to sell
uh products like that and west allen
came up and so we went to west elm or i
called west allen i pitched the idea um
did we just hear that they have a local
maker program i did some googling oh you
did some googling yeah that's not
something i knew about them beforehand
that they had a local maker program yeah
so you could actually sell stuff in
their stores we were advised that
something that big and that expensive
wouldn't really sell because most
purchased items
during a thing like that are kind of
impulse buys like little accessories and
this and that like not everyone goes in
to a pop-up shop or west elm
thinking about dropping that much money
on something that they weren't planning
on doing like if they go in wanting a
chair or a table or something big yeah
they're going to be prepared exactly
they don't just like see these giant
marquee letters and say i want to spend
400 on that let's have them yeah you
know it's like yeah this is not as much
of an impulse decision so we got that
feedback
from work from west allen from west home
yeah well i think we should back up a
little bit
yeah we're kind of jumping around a
little bit yeah we we got that feedback
from west elm and um another piece of
feedback we got because because what we
heard is they have this local maker
program where you can sell stuff in
their stores and when we talk to them
they're like well actually
um in order to do that you first need to
sell
products in store like at these local
pop-ups that we host where basically
makers can just come in set up shop on
one of our tables
and in exchange for like promoting it on
our social media accounts we can we
don't have to you know pay west home a
fee like you do at most craft fairs you
can just go there you know it's another
funny detail i just
remembered we
during the phone call with them that's
when we pitched the marquee letters yeah
and they said that's too expensive yeah
you should do something less expensive
and they're like do you have anything
and we're like oh yeah we have this deer
yeah we're like oh we have this deer
head we probably just like looked around
the room and we were like oh
dear head
and um then they're like do you have a
social media account that you can use to
promote things and we're like oh yeah
yeah totally totally we do we do we
made it that's when we made the evan and
caitlyn instagram account our very first
social media account as evan and katelyn
that's what started it all this one
conversation
with west elm over this thing we never
intended to sell
yeah oh i totally forgot that's a crazy
origin story that's like
yeah i didn't think about it that way
yeah i didn't think about it yeah
because we never had an account like an
instagram account for the blog because
we like weren't actually trying to grow
it or do anything with it it's crazy
that's crazy yeah
so we had so we set up a meeting like in
a few days started we set up the meeting
and then we started the social media
account and then we like launched it and
like posted a few photos tried to get
people to like it and stuff yeah and we
um started making products it was like
90
family and friends yeah follow us all
family friends we started making
products because we had to have a few
examples of things to bring to them yeah
did we bring more than just the deer
head we might have just brought them
over confident with one deer head and
said we can sell stuff yeah we did
change it up a little bit we put like a
wood backing on it because we thought if
we're selling
this we didn't know if like a fully 3d
printed product if that like people
would like that because it's kind of an
unfamiliar material you know we do paint
it metallic so it looks kind of cool
yeah but um we added like a wood backing
to it and like a sawtooth hanger and it
was a very like finished looking piece
and we went and had our meeting and they
were like oh yeah those look pretty cool
do you want to come in like a week yeah
like you should probably have three or
four different types of products the
different price points maybe like one
that's under 15 one that's like this
price one that's the surprise so talking
with them and getting that information
on what sells was really quite valuable
yeah i mean it but also it's like what
sells in what environment you know i
mean it's
it varies a lot yeah it varies a lot but
but um the environment we would be in
would be you know setting up a little
table and
people
coming in to browse and shop
spontaneously buying something yeah
hopefully
so we kind of scrambled and scrambled
made things happen
yeah well and and the pop-up the reason
it was so rushed is because they were
doing this um like more special event it
wasn't valentine's day we did we did do
a valentine's day one it was like a fall
festival
okay
and so they were having a whole bunch of
vendors they're having food there and
like free hot chocolate and
all these like fall decorations and it
was like a whole thing so we got to meet
or like so the downside is there's a lot
of pressure to get it done on that day
because it was like oh it's going to be
a big one
um but it was cool because we got to
meet a lot of other local makers in
houston that was fun and that kind of
helped kick off our instagram and stuff
even more because we chatted about
people and you know we talked to them
about strategies yeah yeah yeah it's
okay to think back to when we had like
50 followers and
i know we didn't know what we were doing
oh we had no idea we're totally like
just totally winging it i what were some
of the um
like
challenges
to you like what were some of your like
memories of challenges during the like
pop-up shop days because we did pop-up
shops for a while at west ham
well i think that let's let's before we
go get on into the pop-ups and selling
stuff i think let's talk about like
like some of the
before things more like like what kind
of like how he financed it and stuff
like that you know so i think that
in the beginning
i was looking at ways to make a whole
bunch of different things for not that
expensive and
uh i wanted it to be scalable at the
same time so my first thought was 3d
printing
one because that's what i had experience
with and i felt like it was pretty
flexible and a lot of the work could be
done without my direct supervision which
is good because
i mean you were
you had just quit your job but i'm
pretty sure soon after that you had
picked up freelancing yeah and so you're
already freelancing and i was working
full-time at the time and you were still
looking into other
like
avenues yeah and then we talk about the
sum in the uh
seven tips for
small-scale manufacturing i think but
also i wanted to
do something that was scalable so if we
got in an order all of a sudden for 200
or something
i could buy like five 3d printers and
have them all running all day long
whereas like if we were doing you know
custom end grain cutting boards or
something that's not
if you get ordered for 200 all of a
sudden you're like oh crap well i have
to say no or hire people or outsource
some of the work or something but it's
like the logistics of that gets a lot
it's pretty challenging yeah it's a lot
more challenging than just buying more
printers yeah so um in in the beginning
i bought the printer for like
prototyping my own products um helping
other people
you know and you know selling the 3d
print services and making these uh
things for west elm and it paid for
itself pretty quickly yeah it it really
did which was surprising yeah because
they had reservations oh my gosh i did
not want to get a 3d printer
they're expensive i did not know what we
were using it for
they're big it's going to be it's going
to be big it's going to be important
it's going to make a difference
something i don't know how i convinced
you i don't know how either it's not a
cheap thing and we didn't really have
like set plans no i mean i trusted that
you would figure something out but also
i mean like you know financially
speaking i didn't just quit when like
we were in a tough situation we had both
been working for a long time we're both
pretty frugal living in texas and with
both of us working a job with no kids we
were we had some savings yeah i mean you
wouldn't have quit if we didn't have
like a healthy enough cushion to allow
you to do that so yeah we had enough
cushion to buy a 3d printer too yeah but
but uh at the yeah i was like we'll just
put it in the closet and shut the door
oh no one sees it
he's not really prepped for anything
i think
now that we've covered that i think
going back to your question of what were
the biggest challenges when we were
starting out the number one biggest
challenge for me
was knowing what would sell
and i think that's the biggest problem
for anyone i mean
almost any challenge can be overcome
when it you know what the challenge is
it's like manufacturing or production or
whatever you know it's like i think that
when you have a concrete problem you can
solve it i mean maybe i'm just being
overconfident but most problems you can
solve in some way if you know what the
problem is but i think the unknown
problems are the biggest because
you can't know what people want and
people don't know what they want
you know it's like if someone told me
like what do you want to buy right now
i'm sure there's tons of things i'd want
to buy if i saw it and i knew it
but i don't know it and i don't
i don't you know it may not exist yet
you know and that like an example of us
not knowing is i think probably what i
would say is our most successful
product
is the the little texas ornaments yeah
which i didn't expect we just kind of
did those only so that we could have a
cheap a really cheap item yeah but they
were like it's not really too much work
that went into them and they're pretty
easy and we're like well we'll just like
throw those in but the main products
will be these like more impressive
things yeah and the ornaments have been
like
they were the most
um successful i think pretty
consistently yeah not only though those
are the main things that sold out again
and again and again yeah exactly
so
i don't know i think that was
interesting that was interesting yeah
and with the 3d printing you know not to
harp on small-scale manufacturing again
but
it was it was really nice to be able to
test out ideas with without the need for
like tooling and new machines and all
sorts of things and you know if we did
want to scale this we could have gone to
molds and other even higher
like higher production efficiency
methods and stuff like that but
i think i'm getting ahead of myself i
think that
one question that we get a lot is how
much were we making
when we were selling all of that how
much were we making
we were making
more than we were spending definitely
and i think that when when i look at the
like dollars per hour we were making an
okay amount between like
10 and 20 dollars an hour yeah for like
our work like our man hours yeah
and that's pretty good you know the main
thing that's that's tough is
the only way to scale that is by either
putting more man hours in
you know like hiring help or something
like that or improving the efficiency of
the manufacturing which also takes time
and money and all of that jazz and then
also you need to be able to move that
much product yeah yeah you can become a
lot more efficient if you know that
you're going to sell 200 of something
every month but it's hard when you're
doing things like like when we were
doing the pop-up shops we would
literally just guess what we thought we
would sell at an event completely guess
we'd go to the pop-up we'd be there for
like six hours and some pop-ups were
great and some were not great oh man
somewhere
painful and when it's bad it's so
painful because you like put all this
work into making all these products and
getting everything ready and making your
table look beautiful and then you're
just like
but i think another thing is
when you're making products you feel
good about your time because you are
making value when you're at a pop-up
store and not selling stuff you just
feel like you're completely wasting your
time it's just like you feel that those
like hours just eat into you
yeah it's really tough but i think that
if we had have kept on going down that
path we would have figured out things
like ramping up social media and selling
online and you know
figuring out what sells and figuring out
what doesn't sell and we could have
gotten much more
efficient selling in larger volumes
that's true well we and we did start
selling in larger volumes because the
way that the program at west elm worked
is um you know you do pop-up shops for a
while and if they see that your stuff is
moving well with their clientele and
you're enthusiastic and you're you know
good about sharing stuff on social media
with them and and all those things then
they can invite you to apply for the
like official local maker program
where and i don't know if it's like this
for everyone but for us we could first
apply to do it in the state of texas so
we
basically got um like talked with you
know people at west elm and got our
stuff in a catalog for the state of
texas so any stores in texas had the
option to order our products and we got
big orders multi-thousand dollar orders
yeah but it was just a lot of work
and we could have you know if that had
kept on growing we would have
scaled it up and made more efficient
products and
yeah but it was still tough because like
you know we we did it in total for maybe
like a year i think
well but also like during this time we
decided to start the youtube channel
yeah and then then those two things were
competing for our time it's like we
could either ramp up in either direction
you know we had the opportunity we could
have like doubled down with products or
double down with youtube
yeah yeah
and we chose youtube but i think let's
not get ahead of ourselves yeah yeah
yeah i think let's talk about the good
and bad parts
yeah i wanted to talk a little bit more
about like the good and bad of doing
pop-up shops the good and bad of doing
wholesale because i think i mean
ultimately like evan just said in the
end we chose to double down on youtube
but i think products would be a better
fit for a lot of people you know it just
depends on like what your person what
you feel comfortable with and all of
that exactly so i think like the things
that we learned and we have touched on
this in a couple of different youtube
videos yeah um
but i think the things we learned during
pop-up shops and doing wholesale and
selling them individually ourselves and
i think that what do you mean like
online online yeah so i think that that
um pop-up shops and in-person events are
very valuable to do but they shouldn't
be your primary source of like yeah
income and stuff like that i think that
they're good to do because you get
an impression
of what people like and kind of why when
you're just selling online
on like a store there's no feedback
other than like did they buy it or did
they buy it yeah and you don't know why
they didn't buy it like like one thing
we we found out that from our pop-up
shops is that like someone would pick
something up a lot but they would never
buy it which made me think okay they
like this it's just too expensive yeah
exactly yeah or they pick it up and
they'd ask how much it is and then
they'd be like ah okay
and then walk along yeah so i think that
in person events are really important to
figure out what you want to do
and then you ramp up either with finding
a whole seller to sell it through or
selling it yourself online online yeah
yeah and
setting up your online store is quite a
lot of work but once you get it set up
right and you have your boxes you have
your packaging you have your labels all
done and all of those logistics are
streamlined i think it's pretty nice but
if you don't have it streamlined the
logistics of shipping and packing and
all of that is
really painful yeah especially when
you're doing like one or two sales a day
you need to like take a break from your
day
re-pull out all that supplies and
you don't have a station for it you
don't have stuff set up for it i think
that once you get a certain volume
shipping isn't bad
but well i mean i would say it's
probably more efficient it's more
efficient and it's not as painful for
some reason because i think like when
you have to take a break from your day
pull out all the packing stuff pack it
take it to the take it to like ups then
that's like
a long chunk of time for one product for
one product but if you're doing like you
know 50
a week and you ship them out once a week
then like you you set aside the time you
print everything at once you put them
all in the boxes of watching take them
all to the shipping place at once i
think that's where efficiency comes in
also i think if you're doing that volume
you're not at the point where you're
like oh i'm working on stuff and oh i
have to take a break yeah dude
my sales are shipping out yay exactly
yeah
yeah
so i and and for for wholesale um at
uh
bigger outlets and stuff like that i
think that has a
big draw because of the the consistency
of the work you know you you know what
order numbers bigger numbers all of that
you have to make sure you have enough
profit margin in your um
uh your sale price so you need to make
things really cheaply and that you have
to be sell you have to be able to sell
them for more to get a good profit
because you know you're sharing your
profits with someone else yeah and
you're sharing like 50
yeah like it's not an insignificant
amount and i do think that
especially when you're smaller i think i
understand the value of that because
when we were trying to sell our own
products and we didn't have a platform
that was painful yeah i mean it's better
to sell
some
you know it's better to sell products
and have some profit eaten up than to
not be selling any of your products that
you've made you know because then you're
not making anything but yeah we didn't
we didn't really have enough of a um
cushion to
make it to like incentivize us to keep
doing the wholesale like enough of a
profit cushion yeah like
like when we were doing pop-ups we you
know we were making a decent amount but
i mean per product not you know we sold
we sold some
but
we sold a lot more doing wholesale but
it was just so much less per product for
so much work yeah um
and i think also another thing is uh
especially with like the deer heads
specifically this isn't something we
thought about when we designed it and it
wasn't a huge deal when we were doing
local pop-up shops but it's a single
item that has to go into a 12 by 12 inch
box yeah
and that's really expensive to ship and
at least with the wholesale program with
west elm we are responsible for the cost
of all of our shipping yeah and so
that's another thing that eats into your
profit margins that you don't think
about yeah you know they're like twelve
dollars just to ship single items it's
so crazy how complex and expensive
shipping is
when like because everyone's used to
amazon now you know you just go online
and it's free and it just shows up real
quick and that's so
unrealistic yeah and like i didn't
realize how unrealistic it was until we
tried to do it ourselves and now i just
feel bad for any company that has to
compete with amazon amazon's just like a
beast when it comes to shipping i know
they're just ruining everybody
oh man and
like i'm used to it too and i i even
know how hard it is to ship and the
logistics and the stalking issues and
stuff like that to some degree
and it's just like oh
ah anyways that's that's another thing
yeah sometimes we'll get questions now
um people who are seeing who have
watched like our old how to sell
handmade products video and stuff like
that and they're like well i went to
your etsy and all you have is t-shirts
now and we're like
yeah yeah cause we're not doing that and
it's really just
okay so let's talk about the good parts
for a little bit because we've been kind
of hovering on the bad parts and why we
moved on no we talked about something
okay so so the good parts is i love
designing products
and yes making them could often be
really fun and therapeutic yeah it was
like a cool opportunity to just put on
your headphones and kind of chill yeah
and do something
like just the right amount of mindless
you know when you're making multiple
things yeah and it was kind of nice and
it's kind of nice and it was nice making
physical things we like making physical
things um
another good part about it was
like well i thought it was a cool way
this was an unexpected benefit but like
meeting the other makers in our area
yeah you know like
and we we haven't um like kept in touch
that well now that we're um so sucked
into the youtube thing but for a while
you know like we got to dinner with some
of the people we made and stuff like
that like we would you know keep in
touch on instagram and it is like it was
a it's a cool community
um and we still like follow them on
instagram and stuff but
um
i thought that was a cool unexpected
aspect and i don't think you would get
that
as much if you weren't doing local
things yeah um which would be that's
another benefit of doing local things
and i also think even if you switch to
doing mainly um
online or wholesale i still think
there's certain times of year like
around the holidays where it's
beneficial to do local things and you'll
get your
money out of your time
another good thing is
you know there's there's kind of a
precedent and there's kind of a path
like a known path
for
stuff like
this like selling products you know it's
kind of like there's books written about
it there's people with experience
there's all sorts of known things
relative to youtube which is like so
unknown and a little bit more chaotic
and
you know it's like it's wild west out
here and like yeah there's less um like
widely applicable tips in youtube aside
from really generic things like good
content
which is completely undefinable yeah but
there's like a lot more
i think because you know people have
been doing it for longer and there's no
experience there are more solid tips i
mean like people have been making and
selling stuff for like forever yeah for
forever yeah pretty much yeah there's
more like places now that you can do it
like with the internet but yeah
yeah um so i think those are some of the
good things the main bad part
is sometimes it got repetitive
yeah sometimes it got repetitive i think
if it was our primary
thing i i don't know if the repetition
would have bothered me but i think
because it well i think the main bad
thing for me is um
it felt started to feel like it was
taking away time from youtube yeah that
was amazing that's why like the
repetitive would get to me because we'd
be like well we came up with this idea
of something you want to do for a video
and it's this new thing it's really cool
but first we got to make 30 more
geometric texases yep you know
i think that
with my experience of making now
i think it would be more fun
because i think we could do more
interesting things i think so you know
with all the creative ways silicon molds
and resin and concrete and like cnc and
all this stuff like we could be like
like production mad houses like would
have like all three three uh all four 3d
printers running at the same time making
things and we could have the c and c
going i would like mold making well i
would have molds like with resin and
concrete in them and like i would
literally be doing only resin
resin only i don't want to do concrete i
don't want to do wood i don't want to do
3d printing i would just do resin just
just like be like resin masters yeah i'd
be like the resin lady like i just want
to do like geodes mainly geodes
but no other stuff too but because this
would be great because caitlyn would be
like making resin would have like a
known thing a solid thing and i'll just
be doing
random crazy things in the background
like
like moonshot projects that like might
be cool or might be complete flops
yeah but i think the reason like resin
appeals to me is because even though
it's repetitive it's different every
time yeah that's totally true yeah and
we could come up with like five main
products at a couple different price
points yeah and you could just be like
doing that boom boom boom that would be
really fun actually yeah like i think if
that if we were going to pick up
products again that's the kind of thing
i would do yeah and i think with with
everything at the very beginning
sometimes things can be a little bit
painful but they're i think that they're
totally worth it
they're totally worth figuring out
and doing um well i think it also like
it helped us learn kind of how to use
social media as a business you know
because we started doing that with the
product business
yeah you know so it's like even if you
think
um you know if you're maybe kind of
interested in doing content creation and
maybe kind of interested in products i
think there are skills that um overlap
you know so you can just start with
whichever one is more in your reach
right now which for us i mean at the
time we started content creation wasn't
really on our radar but i know there's
some people that are interested in both
so
um
yeah there's definitely skills you can
learn they can overlap very nicely but i
think that when we were started doing
both youtube just took over for us we
love making videos we love
exploring and continually pushing and
everything i think it's easier to
overlap them if you're doing custom
products uh yeah you know what i mean
because then you can make a video about
your products and it's different every
time yeah you know if you're making the
same five five products in huge batches
um it's a lot harder to make videos
about that i mean we've done it like we
made like the video that was about
making 80 coasters in one weekend or
whatever you know and so you can do that
but i feel like you can only do that so
many times where if you know you're
jimmy and you're making like custom
signs and stuff like that and it's
different sets of skills every time and
even jimmy says like i felt like i
couldn't do a video on this one because
i was making a sign that's true maybe
the sign isn't the best but you know but
you know he's making a table then he's
making a sign then he's making a knife
cabinet that he's making yeah exactly
yeah so um i feel like that's an easier
way to overlap content creation and
product making if it's custom yeah and
or and or if you're constantly
experimenting with new things even if
it's like let's say that you're doing
resin but you're doing different types
of resin things different molds
different like like like you just do
resin and you do resin and alcohol then
resin and pigment then resin and you
know yeah you could get really
specialized
yeah you could just be like the resin
channel
[Music]
yeah so like now that i'm talking about
i'm getting more excited about it again
but i'm still 100
like committed to this path yeah but who
knows maybe in the future sometime if
like
we want to do some kind of side thing i
don't know yeah we don't have time right
now yeah no we don't have time right now
i think that i think though like looking
back on things if youtube hadn't have
taken off and grabbed hold of us
in such an exciting way
i think that we might have gone down the
path of making products i think so i
think we would have pushed farther into
it
and
um like
sorry go for it i think we would have
pushed farther into it and tried
different
types of making and push farther i mean
we did we were in the process of pushing
a little bit farther like we started
with the 3d printing stuff and then we
had introduced some cnc products to our
library and i think we would have just
continued to and we were we introduced
uh the concrete that was that was
actually pretty early we did this in the
beginning yeah so we had 3d printing
concrete and we were doing cnc we hadn't
even started down the resin yeah we
didn't even start the resin path yeah so
i think we would have continued to like
experiment with new products yeah um
though i do think when you're doing
wholesale it's harder to experiment
because you can't just like put it up on
your shop you have to go through an
approval process yeah it's a big thing
it's like a huge thing to change a price
or to add a product or whatever yeah
but i think that that would have been a
fun path to go down on um
yeah
i think the other aspect now that i'm
remembering through our thought process
is
the fact that we kind of wanted to keep
the business just the two of us
yeah
for the most part i mean
who knows one day we might hire on more
help and we've gone back and forth on
editing and yeah we've gotten some
part-time other help and stuff but i
think that right now we're so we're
we're
so rapidly shifting and dynamic in our
goals and our videos and our projects
and all that we
highly value our flexibility right now
and i think that the more people you
bring on the more responsibility you
take on the less flexible you can be to
some degree
yeah and i do think um
you know with
content creation you can kind of if
things are working you can just keep
doing them and your business grows and
scales with your audience in reach
exactly whereas with products it it
grows when you can make more yeah you
know so it's like so it seems like
hiring someone was inevitable yeah if
the two of us can make like 10 products
per day
or per week or whatever
like number it is at whatever scale
product it is you know we can only get
so efficient yeah
we can't
continue to increase the price of a
table we make yeah you know it's like
it's not like as we get
back like you know it's not like we're
gonna get that much better yeah you know
yeah like the only thing that's the only
way you can cut cost is inefficiency and
time yeah exactly and if you're if
you're charging more for a table it's
got to be a nicer table meaning it
probably takes six more times yeah yeah
so it's like yeah that was another
looking at this scaling
conundrum
where like i i think that like because
we just really liked working from home
and
we like being flexible yeah and those
were like just being able to be in our
pjs and i think that like
going back to the root of why we started
this i think we've touched on this a few
times but we just were going after
a particular life we wanted we wanted to
spend time together we wanted to have a
flexible
work-life balance even though right now
it's all work it was like work work
balance
um
but we wanted all of those things and i
think that bringing more people into the
equation would have taken away some of
that and we might have needed to go to
another location and then it might have
just turned into
um
a work-life balance that wasn't what we
were aiming for yeah
yeah i think so so i think that's why we
chose to do youtube among other reasons
yeah and why we've backed off of
products yeah but products i think are a
really cool solution for a lot of
different people i agree yeah
should we move on to our game
game
[Music]
all right so two truths and a lie how
well do you know me and how well do you
know me pretty well i mean coming up
with these ideas this is really hard it
was really hard because like you know so
much about me
yeah i did i had to like think of things
that happened before we knew each other
which was a really long time ago yeah
okay so i'm i'm sure everyone knows what
two truths and a lie is but just in case
you don't it's basically each of us will
take turns saying three
statements about ourselves two of them
are true one is a lie and the other
person has to guess the lie such as
i took piano lessons
i took the car guitar lessons
i took swimming lessons
which is the lie
okay walk walk them through with me okay
so each one okay well
i know that you were on the swim team
yes i'm assuming you took swimming
lessons at some point as a child
most children
that i knew took swimming lessons so i'm
gonna say that one's true
but the two instruments are throwing me
off because i do not know you as a
person that has musical talent
i'm gonna say that you took piano and
that the guitar is a lie ah you're right
really how did you know
i don't know it i don't know
one or two piano lessons really
and i do not like it
because i think that like the way he
told me to like like the way he was
instructing me i'm like oh no i don't i
don't like that
what part about it did you not like
just everything
i just didn't like the instructor i
guess he was like
he was like oh like i don't know
i guess when you start learning piano
you have to start with like the notes
and memorizing things and stuff like
that and it just wasn't appealing to me
maybe it was just a bad teacher my
brother took guitar lessons oh really i
don't know that did he like it yeah he
took them for quite a while really yeah
oh wow well he took them for a period of
time and he still has a guitar maybe
they have the ukulele yeah so i think
that he's like trying to pick up the
ukulele again
yeah but uh and in swimming lessons i
thought i'd throw that in there because
i've been swimming for my entire life
but like i didn't know because my mom
was also a swim instructor
so i didn't know if like you thought
that like she might have taught me and
then i didn't actually ever take some
lessons and stuff so maybe i was trying
to trick you too much i thought that one
was maybe there was like a hint of maybe
that's a lie because it was so obviously
it's just right right yeah
i tried to be strategic about this okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna try one i've seen
lava in real life
i've gone paragliding i've been swimming
with dolphins
you've been paragliding it's a lie
well dang that was fast
well like lava i know you've been to
hawaii yeah but not everyone sees it in
real life it's like it's like quite a
truck no you you i i know i've told you
that story no but i just know for some
reason i just knew that i couldn't go
there without seeing it yeah yeah okay
so it's like the lava i knew um
paragliding i thought that would have
come up you know it's because like when
we went skydiving you probably would
have brought up paragliding you know
and then what was the third one oh
dolphins swimming yeah then hawaii again
it wasn't in hawaii what was it was it
florida
uh
no but it wasn't california no it was on
a disney cruise and it was on one of the
islands i don't remember where it was
somewhere in the bahamas that just
seemed believable for somebody like why
wouldn't i have told you that i swam
with dolphins before that's really cool
you know how much i like to like do
things with animals yeah yeah okay that
was a pretty good one but i just knew
yeah dang it
okay okay i can hold my breath for two
minutes i've never been stung by a bee
and i'm allergic to scorpions
i think the lie
is
two minutes no i've done it for two
minutes really yeah two minutes can you
still though
i've done it for two minutes
good but that didn't say you you have
done it before that says you can i have
held my breath for two minutes
okay you get one more guess
so the other two are that you've never
been stung by a bee yes and that you are
allergic to scorpion yes sorry that like
one of them being a like negative like a
never and the other one being
okay
i think
i think that you are allergic to
scorpions and you have been stung by a
bee nope i've never been sung by v what
um isn't your mom allergic to scorpions
i know i put that in there to fill me up
you've never been sung by b never been
sung by b
that i guess that's why i'm not as
afraid of them as you are have you been
sung by a bee well i've never been
swimming but i've been sung by yellow
jackets and wasps oh what's the
difference between a yellow jacket and a
b oh yellow jacket or yellow jackets
because bees are good and yellow jackets
suck
yellow jackets are like evil i know
hornets can sting you multiple times
without dying and bees just sting these
all day what about yellow jackets yellow
jackets are just like the meanest bugs
in the world are are yellow jackets bees
no they're not bees they're i guess
closer to wasps i'm gonna look it up oh
yeah yeah yeah evil bees but they don't
look like bees
they're they they're not like not fuzzy
yeah no no not fuzzy they're not cute
and fuzzy they're mean we had a nest at
my house once and i got stung by one and
i was a little kid and i was very upset
i didn't understand why they would do
that
[Laughter]
still traumatized i can see still
traumatized it's happened like multiple
times oh no yellow jackets okay
let's move on
you'll need to dwell on that
okay it's my turn yeah
okay
i used to collect beanie babies i used
to collect coins i used to collect pogs
you'd never collected coins
i've never mentioned pogs to you before
no but like i just know you
you you would caught fire i had a few
coins but i didn't collect them yeah but
also like i know like pokemon you
planted pokemon cards yeah that's why i
couldn't use that one go go along with
them you know well i mean no it was
totally it was like a different era pogs
were before pokemon cards by a decent
amount i collected pokemon cards middle
school you have good ones but i just
know you like your personality
[Laughter]
i should so
yeah i i i
know like
doing that to anyone else
they'd have a hard time i thought i was
so good at my questions
i've never mentioned pogs i had some
good slammers oh man the vlogs are great
pugs are great yeah i i had some i never
like went into collecting them but i
like
you're awesome by the way i think you're
really cool thank you
okay
i used to play soccer i used to play
baseball and i used to play hockey i'm
going to guess the lie is hockey you're
right okay
mainly because like hockey's more
popular up north and you didn't live
anywhere up north i didn't i didn't yeah
i never met anyone who
like played hockey on a hockey i should
have like chosen like another sport that
i didn't play
but i played i played like a lot of
sports i played tennis i played uh
baseball i played basketball i played
soccer what other sports are there
football oh yeah i didn't play that i
should have said football yeah
i'm too tall and awkward i don't really
like this
lanky guy and i've never like run that
fast from the center of gravity's too
high up it was too easy to knock over
yeah like like basketball is the most i
ran in esports i did track and field
like once and it wasn't great
some of these questions are giving me
ideas for like the next time we play
this yeah okay
it's my turn right yeah i almost started
reading
okay
i once won a soccer tournament i once
won the science fair i once won a poetry
competition
oh it's science fair or poetry
competition i'm gonna guess poetry
is the lie is the lie you are wrong oh
was it science fair
you were wrong
i never won a soccer tournament even
though i played soccer for like a year
because i knew you played soccer so long
you played song for so long
i've been i've been to tournaments we
just never won the tournament oh man
you've won matches i've won matches but
if i won a tournament eight years
well shush
because it can't be soccer that was a
good one tournaments that was a good one
yeah so but i did win
i won the um
like my school science fair and the
houston science fair and i went to state
but i didn't want state
yeah you told me that you won the
science fair i remember that story with
the oven yeah yeah we made like like
custom pizza racks for an oven yeah yeah
i don't know how it is
don't it was like the least scientific
science project but we but we had a
really good one
we had a really good competition a
really good presentation yeah we had a
powerpoint we played we played the song
rack em up no no cause we made like
pizza racks and so we would play that on
our booth
oh that was pretty awesome and then i
won a poetry contest do you wanna hear
the poem yes please was that when you
were like four
no i was in like second grade but i won
my school-wide poetry contest and i had
to read it in front of the whole school
the cat yeah it was a cat farm
it is
i have a cat my cat is fat he chewed up
my hat because i shouted scat he's mean
and he's fat i have a big fat nasty old
cat
i watched that video you showed it to me
i just didn't know that you'd like that
was like the yeah i guess
congrats it's good
it sounds like i didn't like my cat at
the time i actually loved my cat at the
time i just thought it was funny all
your cats
[Laughter]
okay i have never seen the sound of
music i've never seen the godfather i've
never seen e.t
you've never seen the godfather i
haven't seen the godfather
that was good because i was like okay
you have to have seen e.t because that's
such a good movie okay
and
sound of music i feel like you've
referred to it once or something i've
never seen this the sound of music oh
wait i got it mixed up sorry no
i've never seen
wait so which movie have you not seen no
no no so i'm sorry
okay so i've never seen the sound of
music i've never seen the godfather i've
never seen et what is the lie
oh
wait so i said you've never seen the
godfather and you said
that's correct
so that's the lie right that's what he
said i've never seen the godfather i've
never seen the godfather you're saying
that's true okay so i can eliminate that
one so it's either so it's either e-t or
sound of music okay sound of music yeah
dang it i i i
would have gotten you he would have
gotten me i thought sounded music was
like that's the one that you seem least
likely to have seen uh yeah and so i was
like maybe he's throwing that in there
yeah
super long so i should have said like i
have seen the sound of music i have seen
the godfather i have seen e.t or i don't
know
you should have just like not gotten
excited when i answered something okay
here i have
i have a similar okay i've never seen
the sound of music what what
i've never seen back to the future
i've never seen pulp fiction you've
never seen sound of music
is that which one
is the truth okay okay oh yeah yeah
truth okay so read it again you've never
seen the sound of music true
oh i did this one
is it is it two fault two politicism
[Laughter]
okay so i need to guess the true one
which is the true one which one
wait wait i'm confused guys we're not
good at this game oh no no it is right
it is it is right it's just confusing
with the negatives it has two truths in
a lie okay so i need to
okay so basically again i've
won
okay you've seen one of these yeah yeah
i've seen i've seen one of these yeah so
i've never seen
back to the future is that true or false
i've never seen the sound of music is
that true or false i've never seen pulp
fiction is that true or false pulp
fiction is the one you have seen that's
false
yeah yes
i almost chose full flexibility that's
the weird thing i almost chose sound of
music and pulp fiction but i know you
know that i haven't seen pulp fiction
because we've talked about pull fiction
oh we have because you've seen it and i
haven't
had this discussion of like cutting
movies you need to see before you die or
something i don't know these lists
picked really bad options
the never ones are confusing because
they're confusing wow okay so
we'll try to keep it like positive yeah
yeah keep it positive i once ate three
cheese pizzas by myself how big
i once ate six items from taco bell
i participated in the formal eating
contest which is the lie
the lie is the formal eating contest
dang it
i shouldn't have said formal eating
contest because like i've i've
participated in an eating contest
everyone's done that because everyone's
like done that with their friends or
family or something right yeah you've
done it i think what was your eating
contest probably the three pizzas
[Laughter]
how big were they they're like uh
or something big
they're all swimming i swam like six
days a week for three hours i ate a lot
i ate like but you know like the michael
phelps thing not that much but like it
was a lot well i knew like taco bell i
knew that's doable because like you
could probably if you were super hungry
eat six taco bell items well that was a
fun that was a fun story my parents
were like
at a charity auction for some reason i
don't know it sounds so weird
but like they're at a charity auction
and one of the things was like an
all-you-can-eat
taco bell
party for like
like a a sports team so me and the whole
swim team went there and all of us like
like we closed down to taco bell and it
was like an all you can eat taco bell
party the best type of party that's
something for our swim team i think we
like my parents got a huge value for
that because like people weren't waiting
on it because taco bell no one else had
a reason to do it so they got it for
pretty cheap i think and like we totally
got a good value for that's it and i'm
guessing you went to cc's with your swim
team too because that's like what all we
did that with our yes with my soccer
team yeah yeah cause it's like five
dollars a person with all the pizza you
can eat and then i think like with my
swim team right how many pizzas can we
let's see
yeah and it was after a practice too so
it's like we had been swimming for and
working out for so long and we're like
so hungry i got a stomachache after that
probably
yeah all right well i thought i'd try to
combine i shouldn't have done formal
eating contest yeah the word formal that
threw it off okay if i had no i still
would have guessed eating contest just
because like the taco bell i was like
that's totally doable you would totally
eat six items yeah the three pizzas i
was like that sounds so exaggerated it
has to be true
because like there's a lot of pizza
that's a lot of pizza and i just knew
that you used to eat a lot
of swim team days okay i have one
i've seen snoop dogg in concert
i've seen the offspring in concert true
true i've seen lincoln park in concert
false
no
what the false one is offspring oh i've
never seen the offspring in concert i
noticed i thought you would have right
you went to a lot of concerts i did
and i would have loved to see them
huh i know because i thought we talked
about like i wish we would have seen
like lincoln park
i've seen lincoln park twice twice okay
but it was in high school
and i saw snoop dogg because he opened
for a lincoln park
that was awesome that was awesome which
is a really weird combo if you think
about it that's weird it's weird right
i visited over
50 countries well this is hard because i
know you've visited a buttload of
countries but i don't know the exact
number you could have visited
49 i want to visit antarctica one day
i don't know all 50 states
antarctica is the lie nah dang it cause
i you know you don't like cold
[Laughter]
oh i want to just throw in some
travel related thing and i had the 50
countries in 50 states i believe that
you totally couldn't name [ __ ]
i grew up overseas i never took us
geography guys i didn't learn the song
like alabama did the north dakota
something
i mean in your defense i don't i don't
know i would have to really think about
it you know the song no i don't know the
song no oh
there was an animaniac song that like
listed the capitals but it wasn't just
the the 50 states i thought we were
talking about states once and you
started like trying to sing a song
there's a song
it was an animaniac song but it
or maybe it was a 50 states i don't know
there's an animation i've lived overseas
for like eight seven or eight years of
my life and i miss out on some like pop
culture things you probably also missed
out on animatics no no and like like
cartoons we got a good amount of
cartoons they're all the old cartoons
but yeah i got the animaniacs okay it
was old enough to still still be there
yeah we got like tom jerry we got space
ghost space ghost coast coast mighty
mouse
that's old yeah and we got the old stuff
we were like watching like cartoon rerun
type stuff it was uh you know you
weren't getting like the new spongebob i
was getting the freshest of cartoons the
freshest memes there weren't memes back
then but no no me there were no memes in
our childhood oh man weird weird
okay your turn
i've unironically worn a vest
i've un-ironically worn a fake nose ring
and i've un-ironically worn chains on my
pants
no jing
i know you
you knew i had a real stylish vest and
cheney pants oh yeah yeah oh i i could
have 100 predicted chain pants because
he went through the hot topic phase i
knew you'd get that one i didn't know if
you get the vest oh no no i i i got the
best really no yeah i could i could kind
of see it could have seen photos of like
your different styles throughout your
life you went through some transitions
because because when i was in like my
hot topic days the nose ring would have
been like a logical thing no but i i i
don't know you you wouldn't have done
the nose ring
a fake nose ring
but you wore it but like no no no
oh man that was pretty good it was a
valiant attempt
okay
i graduated in the top five percent of
my class in high school
for my prom i didn't go out for a meal i
home cooked it
in high school i volunteered more than
100 hours
oh man okay
the things with numbers are hard because
it's like if your number was a little
bit off
like then i could guess it and that
sentiment would be correct but the
number is like one percent off or one
thing off
i
i think the top five percent of your
classes
why would you think that
are you trying to imply that i am dumb
no you just weren't the most studious
i know i didn't do my homework until the
night before what would make you think
that
years of seeing it
but i
i i you cooking for prom i could see
that uh-huh
and
the i actually didn't know too much
about the volunteer hours i was like i
think i was in like a leadership role in
my national honor
national honor society society oh and i
think that to be in that you needed like
do a lot of hours of volunteering yeah a
lot of habitat for humanity oh nice yeah
yeah
cool cool you're making stuff
i've been on the local news about a
week-long snow day i've been on the
local news about a summer heat wave i've
been on the local news about harry
potter i know the harry potter one
because i saw it
okay snow day or
summer heat wave
which one have i been on the news about
you've been on the news for a heat wave
not the the cold one
yeah because i know you've lived there
haven't been that many snow things yeah
but you know about the like north
carolina week of like snow days the epic
week of snow days now i want to find
that clip of the the heat wave what is
that i can recreate
we're at the pool
and there's like the news crew so i'm
the news crew you're the news what do i
say you you ask me how i deal with the
summer heat the crazy summer heat how do
you deal with the crazy summer heat okay
keep in mind i'm like i'm like seven
yeah
well i go swimming in the pool i stay in
the shade and look look drink sunny d oh
my gosh
i happen to be holding a thing of sunny
d and i just went into commercial mode
you were an influencer
at seven
i drink sunny d i panicked and then i
was so embarrassed
and then my parents are like oh we're
gonna watch it later and i was like no
oh i wish they had a tape of that they
might oh they might
i want to find that and put it on their
instagram oh my gosh sonny d hit us up
[Laughter]
i love that i love that
[Laughter]
i have the harry potter clip yeah that
one was later in life yeah
i was very proud to be on the news at
that point i was like
i've never seen lost in translation i've
never seen american psycho i've never
seen silence of the lambs i know that
the silence of the lambs one is true
because we've talked about that and i
want you to watch it i think you have
seen american psycho
so i think that's the lie
really i've never seen american psycho
and i have seen lost in translation
really yeah the interesting thing about
lawson translation i've never seen lost
in translation but i've seen american
psycho the first time i watched lost in
translation well you lost
i was bored i was really bored
throughout the whole movie
the second time i watched it i was like
this is a good movie
really and that's the first time
that's happened to me yeah i don't know
twice i don't know i think it was like
back when when
we like watch movies with friends
like socially and stuff and like
like i watch it with friends twice
and just like you know i wasn't picking
the movie because yeah sometimes you
just watch whatever people whatever
people pick you know
and so they i kind of got forced to
watch it twice
and i'm not forced they didn't like sit
down and say evan you watch this right
now but i don't know it was
maybe i was in a different point in life
maybe
i i went in with lower expectations and
it was better or maybe you like saw
um like foreshadowing or elements that
like tied in to things that yeah weren't
revealed until later in the movie yeah
but the first time
it was just so boring and i didn't care
or something
was it pretty far apart that you saw
them decently far apart maybe like about
a year because sometimes like movie
taste might change yeah i think that it
might
yeah cause and that's kind of like a
artsy or quirky movie it is yeah you
know we're like
i don't know um i think that wraps up
our game segment
yeah
i have even more i want to do so we'll
have to do this again yeah so many games
we've played like i definitely want to
do it again because like they're fun to
come up with questions they're fun to
share things with each other and it's a
good way to share stories with you guys
yeah i wonder how many questions people
got right versus wrong oh yeah you can
kind of like play along yeah so we want
to do two truths and a lie and i also
want to play never have ever with you oh
that would be fun that'd be fun
all righty let's uh get into the thing
of the week thing of the week we need to
come up with the soundtrack for that too
i just did
[Laughter]
the week is
multi-camera editing
[Laughter]
just felt like i should also inhale
air in a weird way in the same direction
i don't know what i was thinking anyway
so i think that multicam editing yeah
the neat thing about that is
multiple cameras running at the same
time used to stress you out you used to
stress me out so much because it
complicates the editing process a ton
it's so much more footage to go through
it like
bogs down your computer more you have to
keep everything aligned anytime you want
to cut your clip and make a shift i
would have to like i would line up you
know let's say four different cameras
camera's worth of clips and if i wanted
to make a shift i'd have to cut four
different cameras worth of footage and
then shift it over
but
you know we've had this suggested to us
before and i just never really
took the time to learn how to do it and
then once i did it was
pretty easy like we'll put a link to the
tutorial i used but you can basically
set it up where it auto syncs different
cameras and then you can
toggle on and off viewing just the
camera you've selected versus viewing
all four or however many of them and you
can select which one you want to show
for each clip yeah unless it's it's so
neat and it's especially handy for like
like the resin projects for example
because we have a lot of
multi-camera stuff going on because you
know with resin you pour it once it's
not something where it's not like you're
going to be making 20 cuts on the table
saw and you have multiple chances to get
it you one chance so you want to get it
from a couple angles is the first
project to use it on the uh battling of
the carts mario karts yeah mario kart
because for the mario kart battle for
the battle itself again you know we had
like a far back view to get us we had a
close-up of the robots we had a top-down
view oh top-down view and one on the
robots we had four cameras running at
the same time yep which is a ton of
footage to go through and it's very hard
to review them when you're constantly
having to just like toggle on and off
each individual track and then you can
view all four at once in the multicam
it's way easier to be like oh that's the
camera i want to go with for this scene
yeah so maybe in the description down
below we'll link
we link to that video you can so you can
like see it in action we'll link to the
um tutorial i used yeah sounds good yeah
awesome this is really fun yeah
okay secret behind the
scenes thing for those of you bonus yeah
stuck stuck till the end the secret is
we're recording this on the 18th
because we're about to go to
workbenchcon in a little bit yeah this
is gonna be gone when it comes out yeah
so this is being released right after
workbenchcon we're recording it the same
day our last episode was released yeah
yeah yeah so uh i just thought that that
was an interesting tip never had to do
it this far in advance i'm glad you
remembered because it's not like
ingrained in our habits to do the
podcast and it's not on our calendar
either not on our calendar yeah we just
kind of remember to record it every
friday or saturday-ish yeah and uh so
yeah
yeah let's end on the bangs
thanks for tuning in guys and we'll see
you next time
[Music]